hey guys Pete peppers here and this is a
commentary walkthrough for candy car
soda level 8 45 pause the video here I
want to talk about it for a second what
the one thing that I noticed a couple
episodes ago was that that you know the
hard levels and so to ablate they seemed
to sort of have a run of themes right
word but it seems like there's a certain
each episode has like similar hard
levels so when I notice it it was all
like honey levels and this one it seems
like the hardest ones are all have the
thick ice and you know it seems like
mostly the way they make these levels
hard is they you know figure out what
the normal amount of moves would be for
it and just take a couple away so you
know you can figure out how to do it for
the most part but you're going to have
to just get it you know get a super run
on it in order to get it done without
using any of the Boosters and probably
part of the reason why they're getting
harder is because they give more
boosters away so they expect that you
have them and if you don't you can just
play you know the fishing tournament or
bubblegum hill or whatever it is so it's
kind of a pain for me to make videos I
always like to make no boosters I don't
really enjoy earning the Boosters as
much just so that I can get through them
I like to just have a level that I can
beat and I think a lot of people play
that way and but a lot of other people
like to be able to earn the booster so
it's just a matter of taste I guess so
this level 8 45 was a really hard one
and took a lot of tries to get through
for me but it was very similar to level
8 30 which was the first hard one in the
episode so the one thing that I came up
with whenever I was working on writing
some tips and things was you know you
can you can get a lot
stuff to happen in this but you just
can't get through it without running out
of moves or using some of your boosters
if you can't set up a colouring candy
plus color bottom combo so what I'm
doing now is I'm just trying to look for
places where I can make a bomb you know
looking for you know spots like this
thread here below the fish where you
have part of the bomb already in place
and then moving the pieces in or like
the blue on this side you know just
moving moving the places into to see if
I can set it up and it's it's pretty
tough to do because you know you don't
have the whole board to work with so you
know obviously in the beginning you can
you can use there's some you know like
wrapped candies and the ice and things
like that that you can use especially if
you make them into rat plush stripe
combos to clear some ice I'll thats can
be helpful but in all the times I played
it to beat this a beauty twice once for
the regular video and once for this all
the times I played it I just didn't get
it I never could get rid of enough of
the layers of ice if I didn't sign up
that combo so here you know I can drop
the yellow and make a bomb so I'll do
that I'm not really going to use the
bomb for anything else and I actually
got a good drop here so I can mix these
together but let's let's look at what
happens here you know we have various
different layers of thickness of the ice
and whenever I make this match it's
going to clear it all off and what
another thing that makes this level hard
is if you if you if you remove the
squares piece by piece the coils
underneath come up so that kind of takes
it long or even to get to the next next
layer down so of course I'm going to
make this combo here i'm not going to
worry about anything else and just
you're going to see that the ice just
come
gets completely cleared out so from
there you know we can we have 16 moves
left so we you know we can likely you
know finish things off without too much
of a problem the coils do make it hard
even if you do get the if you get the
combo but not that many moves left you
know it can still be tough to finish it
off so you know as far as tips go for
this I you know I i would say that just
just work to try to set that set that
combo up and it's tough it'll get
frustrating at times especially what I
noticed happened a lot the first time I
was playing it was that I would you know
set up the set up the match to drop you
know the final pieces in the place for a
bomb and you know something would fall
from the top and mess it up or something
like that so it was always a real pain
but once you get that cleared out it's
not too bad so work on that and
hopefully you get that soon a couple
other things you know you can use you
can you know you can make other combos
in the beginning to just sort of clear
the board out like sometimes if you have
a bomb set in there just using it on a
color is ok because that'll that'll
clear up all you know clear out some
space to get a cascade and might set up
a better opportunity but you know you
don't want to you don't want to play
around too much because you do need a
few you do need a few of the moves left
to clear out all the all the coils at
the end so I hope this will help I'll
put it in the the tips I just wrote up
and make sure that you give the video a
like if you find it useful and subscribe
to my channel check out the guide on the
website I'll put the link here in the
video and we'll talk to you soon thanks